This lecture is about the specific
smoothing methods for language models
used in probabilistic retrieval model.
In this lecture we will continue the
discussion of language models for
information retrieval, particularly the
query likelihood retrieval method, and
we're going to talk about the specifics
smoothing methods used for such a
retrieval function.
So this is a slide from a previous
lecture where we show that with the
query likelihood ranking and smoothing
with the collection language model we
end up having a retrieval function that
looks like the following.
So this is the retrieval function
based on these assumptions that we have
discussed, you can see it's a sum over
all the matched
The query terms here.
And inside the sum is the count of the
term in the query and some weight.
For the term in the document.
And we have TF IDF weight here and then
we have another constant here in the
end
So clearly, if we want to implement
this function using a program language,
we will still need to figure out a few
variables.
In particular, we're going to need to
know how to estimate the probability of
a word
Exactly and.
How do we set alpha?
So in order to answer these questions,
we have to think about this very
specifically, smoothing methods and
that is the main topic of this lecture.
We are gonna talk about the two smoothing
methods.
The first is the simple linear
interpolation with a fixed coefficient.
And this is also called a Jelinek-Mercer
smoothing.
So the idea is actually very simple.
This picture shows how we estimate.
Document the language model by using
maximum likelihood estimate that gives
us word counts normalized by the
total number of words in the text.
The idea of using this method.
Is to maximize the probability of the
observed text as a result, if a
word like network.
Is not observed in the text, it's going
to get zero probability as shown here.
So the idea of smoothing then is to
rely on collection language model where
this word is not going to have a zero
probability to help us decide what non
zero probability should be assigned to
such a word.
So we can note that Network has a non
zero probability here.
So in this approach in what we do is we
do a linear interpolation between the
maximum likelihood estimate here and the
collection language model and this is
controlled by the smoothing parameter
Lambda.
Which is.
Between zero and one.
So this is a smoothing parameter.
The larger lambda is, the more smoothing
we will have.
So by mixing them together we achieve
the goal of assigning non zero
probabilities to a word network.
So let's see how it works for some of
the words here.
For example, if we compute the smooth
probability for text.
Now the maximum likelihood estimate gives us
10 / 100 and that's going to be here.
But the collection probability is this,
so we just combine them together with
this simple formula.
We can also see.
The word network which used to have
zero probability now is getting a non
zero probability.
Of this value, and that's because the
count is going to be 0 for network.
Here, but this part is non zero, and
that's basically how this method works.
If you think about this and you can
easily see now the  Alpha sub D in this
smoothing method is basically Lambda.
Because that's remember the coefficient
in front of the probability of the
word given by the collection language
model here, right?
OK, so this is the first smoothing
method.
A second one is similar, but it has a
dynamic coefficient for linear
interpolation.
It is often called the Dirichlet Prior or
Bayesian smoothing.
So again, here we face the problem of
zero probability for an unseen word like
network.
Again, we will use the collection language
model, but in this case we're going to
combine them in somewhat different
ways.
The formula first can be seen as an
interpolation of the.
Maximum likelihood estimate and the
collection language model as before as in
the JM smoothing method.
Only at the coefficient now is
not the Lambda a fixed number, but that
dynamic coefficient in this form where
mu is a parameter.
It's a non-negative value.
And you can see what if we set the
mu to a constant.
The effect is that a long document
would actually get a smaller
coefficient here.
Because a long document that will have
longer length, therefore, the
coefficient is actually smaller.
And so a long document would have less
smoothy as we would expect.
So this seems to make more sense than
fixed coefficient smoothing.
Of course this part.
Would be of this form so that the two
coefficients would sum to one.
Now this is one way to understand that
this smoothing
Basically it means it's a dynamic
coefficient interpolation
There is another way to understand this
formula.
Which is even easier to remember, and
that's this side.
So it's easy to see.
We can rewrite the smoothing method in
this form.
Now in this form we can easily to see
what changes we have made to the
maximum likelihood estimate which would
be this part right?
So normalized count by the document length
So in this form we can see what we did
is we add this to the count of every
word.
So what does this mean?
This is basically.
Something related to the probability of
the word in the collection, and we
multiply that by the parameter mu.
And when we combine this with the
count here, essentially we are adding
pseudo counts.
To the observed text.
We pretend.
Every word has got this many pseudo
count.
So the total counts would be the sum of
these pseudo counts and the actual
count.
Of the word in the document.
As a result, in total we would have
added this many pseudo counts why?
Because if you take a sum of this.
This one, over all the words that we see,
the  probability of the words would sum to one,
and then give us just mu.
So this is the total number of the pseudo count that we added
So this probability
would still sum to one.
So in this case we can either see the
method.
Is essentially to
Add these.
As pseudo count to this data pretend
we actually augment the data by
including some pseudo data defined by
the collection language model.
As a result, we have more counts.
I still.
The total counts for a word
would be like this and as a result even
if a word has zero count here let's says
we have zero account here and it would
still have non zero count because of
this part.
So this is how this method works.
Let's also take a look at some specific
example here.
Right, so for text again, we will have
10 as an original count that we actually observe, but we also add some pseudo count.
And so the probability of the text would
be of this form naturally.
The probability of network would be
just this part.
And so here you can also see what's
alpha sub d here.
Can you see it if you want to think
about, you can pause the video.
Have you notice that this part is
basically alpha sub D?
So we can see this case.
Alpha sub D does depend on the
document.
Because.
This length depends on the document, whereas
in the linear interpolation the JM
smoothing method.
This is a constant.